enseigner les foulées sur le tapis
soulever des poids conflit des muscles
suez
c'est désormais devenu une pratique de
masse à se demander ce qu'ils ont tous
un objectif
cette poussée nationale jusqu où est-ce
qu'on peut aller jusqu'à sept corps et
essayer d'augmenter semaine après
semaine les performances moi je fais du
sport collectif à côté et puis du coup
j'avais envie d'avoir des séances
supplémentaires pour ma santé physique
pour l'autre cas moi je vais avoir
bientôt 60 ans pour l'entretien on est
tous pareil avec les années ma famille
les enfants prend plus de temps pour soi
on se laisse aller plus d'un moment ils
vont se dire non il faut que je prenne
soin dans le domaine des salles de
bourse ou disons jacky bio digestive
kurdes historiques
il est installé depuis 1990 avec des
abonnements mensuels allant de 27 à 45
euros soit club compte entre 600 et 1000
adhérents sont atouts la proximité
en effet sa forte hausse comparé aux
salles où on n'a pas de coach ici si on
a un problème on sait pas quel appareil
utilisé alliage acquis en trente ans il
a vu la pratique du sport en salle
prendre de l'ampleur mais depuis
quelques temps son chiffre d'affaires
baisse et a de plus en plus de
pratiquants il ya plus en plus de salles
donc on est passé julien une métisse 20
salles à 45 la raison en cinq ans donc
sur dijon c'est beaucoup moins 40 mais
pas loin je pense c'est pas loin plus de
hautes vagues qui arrivent encore des
grosses salles et six de plus annoncé
pour 2019
les ouvertures de salles sont fréquentes
à dijon est dorénavant les franchises au
pris le pouvoir
les professionnels tablent sur une
demande qui va encore augmenter en
france celui pour soir de la population
est cliente régulière ou occasionnelle
contre 11% en allemagne ou 13% en
angleterre de quoi aiguiser les appétits
des chaînes qui s'affrontent sans pitié
le dernier arrivé c'est basique vita
chesnoff une marque hollandaise qui mise
sur des fal très grande et des prix
tirés vers le bas une concurrence accrue
qui amènent des acteurs à se réorganiser
pour résister la part qui tu laisses a
choisi de grossir on a saisi une
opportunité de rachat du groupe next
alice qui comporte les trois marques
historiques amazonien giga jim white
club et ça nous a permis de passer de la
9e à la 5e place des clubs de fitness en
france parmi les 30 enseignes qui sont
référencés dans un récent sondage les
habitués déclare choisir leur salle en
priorité en fonction des horaires
d'ouverture et du prix ici c'est ouvert
de 6h à 23h et pour éviter de trop
baisser le tarif encore on voit la
deuxième série travail la salle propose
les services de courge veut offrir la
facilité d'une franchise de pour par
exemple nous être sur toute la bourgogne
on va voir même comme à dijon quatre
centres vous pouvez très bien travailler
en centre ville allez vous entraîner en
centre-ville habité sur la toison d'or
venir chez nous et le côté humain
le marché ce segment dont du low cost à
20 euros par mois
haut de gamme à près de 50 un secteur
d'activité de plus en plus concurrentiel
la compétition pour survire s'annonce
musclé